みなさーん
[音楽]
鬼げーいい食べまーすかワールバーれっ japanese
空港は日本に生まれて
夢だから日本人の皆は卓効を遂げるくーんっぺ
wii ライスええええ
コンビニおにぎり売ってると思うんですよ結構いろんな味の人気があると思うんです
けれどもその中でも特にスタンダードかつ
基礎となるおにぎりとは何かそうしよう結びでございますこれこそがおにぎりの頂点に
して原点だと思うんですよね
はいどこちらに3社分買ってきましたこちらセブンイレブンの使用結びお値段は税込み
で108円です阻止
こちらファミーまあどのシオン sb お値段100円ですしはずらのに君
ローソンの使用に切りこちらも値段が100円で先に行っておけばその他の味音痴なん
で正直味はどれでもいいんです大事なのは両
強い私なりにフォーカスしたかと言いますと味ではなくて病なんですよねまあローター
も写メファミマも100円7だけが108円でちょっとインタビュー
たんですけども例えば1000粒だったら線する100円なんですよ
すぐにですねそれ分かることによって1粒あたりの値段が分かるということでどの米粒
が一番安いのか
一番大人のかっていうのは光害地演奏していこうと思いますまあもちろんすべてのこの
おにぎりが同じすぐじゃないと思うんであの今回をも偶然たまたま切るとお前らのせい
だ何コレ馬鹿で運なので仕方ないと思いま
ならだいたいこんなもんなのかなってだいたいも
高程度まで見ていただけるとありがたいなと思っています今回分かることはアジア全部
美味しいなわかってるんですよどの子を部数岡山
一番米粒がたくさん付いてくるのかそしてお得に買えるのか
個別部1つあたりのねらーを計算していこうと思います俺これ大丈夫かな
ちょっとどんな月限定からかわかんないんですけどそこは頑張っていいこと
頑張りますで雲よ
はい体でまずはさ3羽カラス数えていきましょうかすっごい美味しそうですよね
やっぱり僕具材に迷ったら結構使用的で食べちゃうんですよねでは避け数えていき
ましょう
リアルプロワンちゃん前して終わるな
goo
これからでピンセットで一つ物まで行こうと思いますローマって人生終わったらこれ
おにぎり1個とかならわかるんですけどもこれ今から3個ありますからね
僕は正確にね皆さんにどのコミュのニールが買えば一番お得なのかをわかっていただき
たいのです
きっ
結構で急いでもで皆さんもね気になってると思うんですよどうで似たような値段で買う
のであればたくさん入ってた方がいいなって思う人は多いと思うんですよねつだけで
しっかりと数えていきましょう
[音楽]
はいというで100粒並べ終わりました
減りませんねぇ
あっはっ
ああああああ
心霊
[音楽]
ん
wh
やっ
[音楽]
ん
お薬粒くらいてくると思ったんですけどやばいのやってもやっても減らんぞ
[音楽]
包まれましたこれやばいなぁ1個目でこれかこれ1れ家じゃ終わらんぞ
じゃあようやく粒行ったんですけどもあとこれだけ残っています全然緊急があるくらい
入って行きですねちょっと一人だと思う限界を感じたのでちょっと手分けしてやる事に
します
[音楽]
ん
はいというわけでこれで線する行きました
先着ででこんなもんでございますで残りがこんなもんでしまって本当にやばくねこれ
ああああああ
やってやろうぜ
[音楽]
ん
長いなぁちょっとすることじゃねーな
[音楽]
car
hoge てきたーーーー犬さベリー窓の人気で終了しましたーー
だったからマッハついてくれございましん
[音楽]
でもさ2617粒でございましたーーー
で
1粒あたりの値段を出していきましょう1つ当たり0 de ja 3821字ロック
救援ということが分かりましたおめでとうございます
次でセブンイレブンのおにぎり解放していきましょうセブ m だけでなんか108円
でちょっとた妻の姉
昆布粒1粒あたりの単価がどうなるかがとても気になります早速
数えていきましたパターンでは頑張っていきましょうはい
ええええええ
[音楽]
います
ん
入ってっ
[音楽]
ああああああ
特にされるねぇーただただきついですすぎて数え考えていきましょう
はいえー2436さあでございましたよっ
米1粒当たり0 ja ねぇ443349初宴でございましたーーー
結構高いね
ではあのを握る時代が180円ナンデコメのタンクがタグんくなっているようですそれ
がおいしいのかも知れませんしは分からないです
味に子だもんだなあスタッちゃった
幸いですあげじゃーん
青木詐欺や全然わかんない質問
web しちゃってございますんでは食べてみましょう
[音楽]
ウェイっ
バーン
あああああっはぁ
えっ
voodoo
yeah
ああああああああ
あーだぜ無理もう一あってくださいしずかもしんねぇ
してくれた
腕痛い反日が出ず去っているとうでーが言いたくなってきます
me
[拍手]
mar
うん
ネトウヨっ分極でない
[音楽]
はい取り上げライブ中盤に差し掛かっております2日前からちょっと行って始めてるん
ですけどもだいたい計算するとズーム時間ぐらい
わかります
人ともに前回でここさんに今めっちゃ臭いイライラしております指が入ったって目も
良く見えなくなってきました
撮影ですもうすぐ完成するのでもう少々お待ち下さいません
ありましたぁー
3人がかりでようやく半日かけて終わるぐらいの米爪な感じでした
店お米には感謝しましょう愛媛数えます
作ってみて
10本
はいローソンのおにぎりの個別日の数は2765粒でした
そしてひと粒あたりの値段が0.03616637円ということがわかりましたーー
相次ぎで比較してみましょうか a 米粒の数を見ますとファミリーマートが2617
粒
セブンイレブンが2436粒ローソンが2765すぐでローソンが一番多い術科になり
ましたね兄がファミリーマート西が7ということになりました
結構本気で正確に測ったんですけどもツイート1粒あたりの女だんですね
どんどんおにぎりを買えば一番たくさん2部が食えるかっていう計算によると一番た
ちょっとを伸ばす
セブンイレブン一粒0.04433498円続いて funny ワードガレージ年齢
3821169園
そして最後にローソンが0.0弾61663らないという結果になりました
壱番館てお得なのはローソンということになりましたねこうさ店かもしれないんです
けど一応根源活動に木ではこういう結果になりました
またまあ米の中でだとかヒンスと
もいろいろあるね味の法案と全くよくわかんないんですけどもお得に買いたいって言っ
たはローソンのオススメなのか
すみません
ねます
me